all right ready boys
hell yeah
hello welcome back to another episode of
the trash taste podcast I am Joey and
I'm with the boys gone and Connor as per
usual hey how are you doing guys welcome
so I'm gonna try something different
this week guys we're actually we're
actually going to try to get this
episode out in a timely manner oh we're
talking about some topical stuff maybe
we are maybe well what makes you want to
talk about topical stuff today gone what
makes you want to talk about topical
stuff there's a few there's seems to be
a lot of things have come out recently
that normally we'd be like uh this isn't
this episode's not gonna come out in
like two months or something so we're
not even gonna get the chance to talk
about it but we'll try something new
let's uh Spice in let's slice and spice
in oh my God my brain is broken let's
splice in some topical episodes every
now and again and uh see ya see sure
what should we start off with I think
one thing that uh kind of took the
entire internet by storm especially the
content creator sphere was the xqc story
yeah of uh how he signed a 100 million
dollar deal
which is [__] insane you know like
the one that shocked me the most about
that is like obviously 100 million
dollars a lot of money especially for
like a streaming deal but it's like it's
the fact that this man's deal was bigger
than LeBron James's
well blood money is an interesting thing
you see gambling money is different yeah
normal people money yeah it doesn't it
doesn't apply yeah yeah apparently that
was like a I mean it was he wasn't
confirm but it was very obvious that he
took some Equity yeah that the kick
which is a oh yeah full disclosure I
have a streaming deal with twitch yeah
not not 100 million dollars yeah I think
we would have heard about it if it was
full disclosure I don't have a streaming
deal uh at all yes yes guys yeah full
disclosure I don't Stream
So with three different people I say it
blood money but my I have twitch is
Amazon so it's a different kind of blood
money yeah pissing the bottle money yeah
um as we said I think the one thing that
like kind of made me question everything
first was just like where was kid
getting this money and then I looked
into it and I think like steak.com which
is the company that gambling company
that owns kick I think like in the
correct if I'm wrong but I think that
like last year they were worth like
couple of billion dollars I think
they've made like 2.6 or something in
the revenue
something like that Jesus uh I mean it
just goes to show where like even you
know a lot of these like I guess when
they play like casino games they're like
guys don't don't do this I'm just I'm
just doing it because I need to get paid
clearly it works oh clearly let's show
that doesn't work yeah I think people
are just doing this and playing slots
mindlessly for hours clearly has an
effect and makes people want to play
these things yeah of course I mean
you're seeing it put right in front of
you and then you're telling people hey
you know this thing that's right here in
front of you yeah don't do that yeah I
mean I I have a feeling that I'm not
sure if this is going to be a one-off
deal or not just because I have a
feeling a few other craters as well I
don't know how much though I mean yeah
we don't know how much but obviously xqc
got paid this much and this was this
with this amount of money it's just like
a headline generator you know what I
mean you basically paid this much money
not just to bring what over one of the
you know the biggest streamer right now
in the in the pla on the platform on any
platform I believe uh to your platform
but also it's just 100 million dollars
in terms of marketing because this is
the most organic marketing you can get
because people are talking about it
everyone's writing about it and uh it's
now people are whether they like it or
not people are talking about kick
there's a massive massive conversation
about Kik as a platform and it's kind of
like it's almost genius in the way
because even though like YouTube is like
obviously a much more established
platform it almost seems like YouTube as
a streaming platform is just like the
third party you know no one's it's
because YouTube's putting like zero
effort into trying to improve the
streaming experience on YouTube right
like they're honestly it tries to I just
think it doesn't know what the [__] it's
doing I don't think it's trying as hard
though as like saying yeah yeah I think
the problem is is trying to integrate
streaming into a into YouTube which is
predominantly video and the whole
platform is built around serving you
video how do you kind of integrate live
streams in a way that kind of works yeah
uh and so but also in general I mean I I
like that these big deals are coming out
this is good for all of us and me
specifically I'm very happy exactly hey
that means more negotiating power
sitting in there being like please yeah
me next please I mean you know if if if
these other companies you know because
because twitch twitch has made many many
blunders in the past year or two in the
past month or so I'd say this this
company this website
it's literally like just watching like
[__] Jerry going ham wait with Jerry
the mouse or Jerry's the mouse that's
your [__] Tom
happen on the rake walking into the
shotgun yeah it's like everything he
just kick his Jerry and Thomas twitch
right now yeah and the thing the the
funny thing is uh you know even if
kicked wasn't doing these massive things
it just seems like a lot of websites a
lot of platforms are just having W's by
just doing nothing you know by just not
being twitch and making well if twitch
had done [__] nothing for the past
two years I think it'd be still be fine
but they [__] everything out
um it's so [__] I think it's while
the about this xqc deal that just
shocked me was obviously you know the
size of the uh the contract as well but
it's also the fact that it's a
non-exclusive so this man literally just
got 100 million dollars from this
website and then they were like yeah you
can continue to stream actually I think
I think this is a um this is a much
smarter way of doing it I think that
when um from like Kix perspective or any
competitor because I think we look at
when like it happened with like ninja
and mixer there was like a big thing for
a little while but then okay Ninja's on
mixer people aren't on mixer yeah right
and then twitch uh Ninja is now not on
Twitch to kind of like Usher people
towards mixer right yeah but if he's
streaming on both and you're a big
viewer of the twitch platform you like
watching uh your streamer on on Twitch
or another platform you know and you're
let's say every week of streaming twice
a week on both that's two times a week
where you'd be like hey guys you like
this come come to this other platform
where I'm gonna be doing it again
tomorrow so I think it's a way of kind
of like constantly making sure you're
getting an ad on the other platform yeah
to your own platform
ad spot on Twitch for kick yeah and then
that way they can also then sell it to
the Creator being like no no don't worry
you don't have to you don't have to
abandon what you already have you can
still do it and also there's probably
it's probably easier for the streamer to
then take that
um because also probably less money for
them to have to pay but they're like
okay well it's not like a giant change
it's like I don't have to stream twice a
week on that it's not a big deal it is
absolutely a big deal and you and it's
very hard to manage doing that but I
think that's the Real Genius behind the
non-exclusivity obviously we've seen
exclusivity from everywhere yeah but I
think having that is might might be the
future we'll see I think it's pretty
smart it's a very smart movie YouTube
doesn't need that [__] though because
YouTube's already got it on lock with
you with video streamers need their
videos on YouTube yeah I mean you
YouTube doesn't need to like invest to
get into the streaming space sure they
could be like a jack of all trades
master of one which is like the video
platform which is kind of what it is
right now you know YouTube shorts is not
hasn't taken off as much as like
something like say tick tock
um same with like the YouTube gaming
YouTube streaming it's just kind of
there it's just like oh you watch videos
where we have these other things as well
you know but it's not like it's never
gonna be known for that I don't think
YouTube is doing a lot of good stuff
though I uh stuff that I I as a streamer
I recognize I like it's pretty handy
like it used to be that
you know when you stream on a YouTube
channel uh that Vaude would just either
go unlisted automatically or just go up
yeah right but now they've separated it
so now it's home which can be like your
normal tailored videos highlights and
then there's live which has all your
vods yeah which is great because like
for right now for me on my twitch I like
I have a vlog Channel I have Eclipse
Channel I have a [__] shorts Channel
I have a highlight channel it's like all
the [__] is separate and YouTube is
slowly making it the one just stop for
everything yeah and that allows you to
kind of aggregate Subs as well whereas
all my Subs are all split in between
like 9 900 goddamn channels
I've also noticed it all just it also
makes it really confusing to see why
someone has subs you know sometimes [__]
yeah sure sometimes you go on a channel
they have like one million subs and you
see their latest videos and they get
like 10K views yeah you're like why the
[__] do you have oh and you click on the
shorts Tab and it's just like 10 million
views yeah 30 million views I was like
okay now that is true it does kind of
create confusion and like I feel you
know if you've been on YouTube for long
enough and you stumble upon a channel
like that then you automatically just
think oh they're either not active or
it's a dead channel so it's like you you
already have this kind of image so like
there are some good and bad sides to
that whole thing but um I I don't sub to
anyone on YouTube anymore
um I just thought the the
recommendations do everything now I have
stopped I I literally don't stop anymore
really I've noticed if I just watch a
channel enough it'll always appear on my
recommended I own I very rarely sub uh I
only sub if I know I watch something and
I'm like I want to make sure I remember
that I like this person yeah because I I
do the same thing I let my wreck I've
met like [__] AI recommendations I
just made it so that the sub is
basically useless yeah it's it's near
it's very it's not like we make any
money it's very very close to being kind
of defunct and just this kind of nice
fun number yeah that certain creators
it's a clout value but do you notice
that because your life is like uh
revolving around recommendations that
you always go into like certain holes or
certain like rabbit holes I'm sure if
anyone like one random recommendation
you got on that week and you're like oh
that's actually a really interesting
topic and then you go that and that's
your rabbit hole for the week and then
you go to like the new rabbit hole yeah
yeah I've I've not which is why I still
do SUB to creators because just in case
that Creator is not in the rabbit hole
that I'm in for that week I'm like I
want to remember that I still like this
kind of content uh even even if I'm not
watching that Comic Con and I watch too
much content on YouTube to like go back
through my history to be like all right
where is it where was this one video I
saw that I really liked yeah yeah
exactly yeah but I mean like I think
streaming is just streaming's like you
know streaming is a very interesting
space and shows like short content you
know the way it's it's funny because the
way I see YouTube now and long form
video content YouTube's slowly turning
into TV for the internet you know it's
slowly turning into like the old media
let's just say everyone kind of like
yeah yeah everyone it's funny because
remember when YouTubers try to get on TV
and everything now people on other
platform are trying to get on YouTube as
we all know you can't grow on Twitch
unless you have a YouTube channel that's
kind of like popping off that's the only
way to grow same with Tick Tock as well
well tick tock's an entirely different
thing but shorts don't make nearly as
much money as YouTube does so everyone
really wants to be that YouTuber so I
think that's part of the reason why
YouTube just seems like a more stable
platform now is because we forget that
in the days of the internet YouTube's
actually pretty ancient now it's been
around for a pretty long time you is the
only and I think mocks wrongly said this
as well it's the only stf platform still
I think no other platform feels as
polished and as good as YouTube all
right PornHub no no no there's so many
scandals
that's triple s in terms of
entertainment yeah in terms of in terms
of the actual platform all right in that
case then what tier if we if we're going
by platform tier lists what would you
put twitch at right now I don't know
recent changes YouTube is
detail I mean like the interface and the
community there is great but I think
Twitter's just really been struggling to
just figure out what the [__] they want
yeah uh and it's obviously they're like
I mean I'm assuming the the the reason
why they're kind of making these these
choices is because they're losing money
I'm guessing and I I yeah I don't know
it's just kind of like the whole 70 30
thing and they took away 70 30 from
creators yeah which um for more
background
um twitch is very uh publicly been a 50
50 company so if you subscribe to
someone you get 50 of that yep all right
then yeah this is a fun game and uh yeah
yeah and then there was a secret 70 30
uh which I found out about maybe like
after a year of being a partner and I I
you only haven't heard about it from
Word of Mouth like some people just had
it and then you were like oh and the
only way to get it was to ask right
apparently there was like a secret
criteria they didn't talk about it was
very I mean if you're if you're a
decently sized pretty achievable uh and
they had this and a lot of the top
streamers were on this thing and I was
on it for like two months
and then they revoted it and they said
we're not doing that anymore it's not
happening we're losing too much money
yeah yeah and it was kind of a bizarre
Choice really because it only really
affected the the the top creators and
obviously the top creators are going to
be vocal and have the biggest followings
yeah so it just looked way worse than it
was and I think if someone calculated it
only actually affected like a thousand
craters right out of the whole twitch
platform which I think has like 40 000
partners and then however many others
it's a lot it's like yeah but I guess on
Twitch a lot of the power or viewership
is very weighted at the top yeah yeah
um
so they removed this and it looked
terrible for them and now they're
bringing it back and then they publicly
showed the criteria and now it looks
even worse because now they're showing
what you had to get for it and it
doesn't look good and especially for
small creators as well yeah and it
doesn't even benefit the big big craters
because after one hundred thousand
dollars which someone like actually see
what we're making in like [__] three
days you don't get in benefit from the
70 30 anymore so yeah it really didn't
benefit many people and it was just kind
of like a weird Band-Aid Solution on all
the fuck-ups they had and then recently
they they changed all the sponsor stuff
which was like yeah that was weird
because it was like them basically
Banning any events like it's because I
mean like you know I've got the charity
event coming up which uh is happening on
the 29th of June uh yeah it's tropical
so we can talk about that
um and that that would have just like uh
killed that yeah or like any kind of
event like that is done yeah yeah
because that you know these are events
that often cost upwards of six figures
and it's like okay well most most people
can't afford to pay that out of pocket
they need a sponsor they need someone to
help kind of alleviate the costs yeah
yeah so twitch saying hey you can only
you can't have burned in ads into the
stream which just means an ad that plays
on the stream outside of Twitter's
control yeah yep
um them saying no to that is being like
we don't want anything highly produced
on our yeah so like Esports events like
you know like smash tournaments or
conventions and stuff like that but just
all be gone but obviously the caveat is
is that this is already pre-existing on
platforms like YouTube YouTube is the
same rule right uh that you can't have
ads in the video yeah oh really but it
it is a nice I think it's like a it's
like a a thing that they have which they
use when someone is using it egregiously
yeah you're right well I think twitch
has two massive issues right now which
yeah PR is a big thing and part of the
reason is I think this this is what
happens when you are so reliant on such
a small percentage of your user base
right I'm the top 100 creators makes up
for like most of the user base so if
someone complains you have to listen
yeah [__] hundreds of YouTubers could
complain about a certain decision but at
the end of the day dislikes aren't
coming back they make a decision and
they stick with it no matter what you
know uh they have that power but with
twitch has doesn't have that same you
know have done that YouTube is the stoic
parent where it's like if I say no it's
no and twitch is that parent that's like
well you've been a nice boy yeah so I'll
bring it back
are you okay with your Christmas tree
you don't like it okay I can change it I
can I can change it the wise thing that
YouTube has done is obviously it's
introduce demonetization all that but
it's never [__] with the money splits
yeah I think that's just something you
just don't do yeah you don't take away
you directly say you're taking away
money from creators yeah I think it's a
disaster because then you just you're
you're souring your creators to a point
that and no other decision could piss
them off this much than being like hey
I'm going to affect your business model
I am going to [__] you it's literally
hey how about you make it less money now
yeah yeah you have no control
what our YouTube did this with certain
things but I I think YouTube did it in
certain ways because it had to yeah you
because you know YouTube has a vested
interest in making sure you make the
most money yeah and demonetization was
there to make sure that everyone
unfortunately was like kind of a
necessary evil at the time because I
mean let's be real YouTube is in a
[__] weird place yeah when they
introduced it and it kind of needed it
it was kind of the wild west and I think
demonetization is it doesn't work
perfectly yeah it doesn't work perfectly
but it is a system that is needed in
order for the platform to be able to
grow to the size that it is now uh
twitch doesn't have that right now
twitch is still a very young platform
twitch is still in the wild west uh I
mean I feel like I don't know anymore
it's pretty [__] old uh if we're
talking like Justin TV era yeah but I
mean if you compare it to like Justin TV
like it's you know Justin TV I feel was
like the true Wild West right like
because that was that also came out
during the time on the internet where
the internet was just the wild west but
now that you know people are taking
streaming and video platforms like
YouTube and switch way more seriously on
a business side of things as well and
like a corporate side of things now I
feel especially on Twitch like even just
within like the past couple of years I
feel like it's just gotten so much more
stricter and more like confined in what
people can actually do unless you're a
massive Creator then you can get away
with a lot of well that's that's what
every social media platform happens uh
that's what happens when a platform
grows to enough of a size yeah uh when
people start getting worried about
getting sued then you need to worry
about putting in policies and policing
them which is what we saw from YouTube
when people have to worry about
advertisers dropping out that's when
people start to worry especially like
you just follow the money and it makes
sense yeah of course something like Kik
is like even more of the Wild West than
Twitches right now but that's because
it's a growing platform yeah if it grows
to enough of the size you're going to
see the same problems that twitch is
dealing with with right now absolutely
uh you can't you can't get away from
that [__] because companies need to make
money every uh now like somehow yeah you
know it's frustrating I like yeah I like
twitch a lot of stuff [__] up I'm
really actually you know obviously I
like twitch as a platform a lot I would
just like Twitter because it seems like
everything twitch is doing right now is
reactive rather than proactive yeah yeah
it's I think that's the big problem you
never want to be reactive in a business
you always want to be like ahead of
things yes and everything they seem to
be doing is just a reaction to something
that's [__] up and it's always the
worst reaction yeah it just feels like
the people making uh some of the
decisions just feel very disconnected
from yeah what creators and viewers want
yeah
um it's just confusing yeah a lot of the
stuff makes no sense it's like what do
you what why have you ever thought about
trying to stream on kick
is a massive PR problem yeah the
creators on there the the companies that
how would we rank kick we ranked twitch
how would we run so twitch's DTA YouTube
is this too where would kids like dog
[__]
it's so bad yeah even with the 95.5 yeah
that's fine but like there's a caveat
there's there's like the it has a giant
PR problem yes the creators on there
the the again the main the main category
as a very recent is still slots and
gambling there's a lot of a lot of
questionable stuff yeah I mean my
biggest
problem yeah I mean my my biggest
problem right now is that I don't
believe the 95.5 okay here's okay here's
the thing right here's the thing is
unreal here's the thing
it's 95.5 now yeah but tell me how them
tell me how they're making money through
95.5 yeah because I mean there's a lot
of speculation yeah there's a lot of
speculation on different business models
but there is no actual guarantee
um and it's the oldest uh the oldest
philosophy I know of if something sounds
too good to be true most of the time it
normally is kick is this the new kid on
the block that's got this shiny dangling
like oh come to our platform it's 95.5
but let's say it does grow to the size
of twitch who's not just who's to say
that they're not going to encounter the
exact same [__] problem what's that
what's to say kick is also going to pull
a twitch and being like yeah
let's pull it back to 70 30. yeah I mean
right now when I see kick I'm I go on
Kick and I'm like this is just a carbon
copy of twitch except it has gambling
well yeah I think the real money is the
gambling yeah it's going to be more used
as a vehicle for getting people into
advertising I think that's how they're
making the money right now is the fact
that again like the majority of kick
right now is gambling on sites like
State I think it's hard it's hard to
Encompass how how lucrative gambling is
it's very very very profitable as we all
know but yeah I think enough so that one
website of gambling would be enough to
just prop up a whole [__] chemical
system yeah easily I think so I think I
think I think it makes that much money
it's terrifying and I think obviously if
you've got more creators on it that that
could go up uh that two point whatever
billion it easily could go up I think
yeah it's like come to kick we'll give
you 955 and you can make us some extra
money by gambling on our website
funneling that back into kick so that
kick stays afloat so it's just this like
Loop of money that's going around yeah
yeah I mean I think right now it's funny
like yeah the biggest problem with Kik
is the pr problem it seems like anytime
there's an [__] doing something in
Japan or anything it's just like oh they
were streaming on Kik and I was like
great because every time
every time I'm looking up news for the
second channel to be like all right
let's see uh what's been happening in
Japan today and if the if the article
starts off with kickstream I'm just like
oh God
that's like a huge problem right where
you think kickstream when you should
think probably a problematic negative or
someone racist yeah I mean like that's
just like that's just not something you
want yeah you know and I think a lot of
people don't I think a lot of people no
matter how much money you throw them
would not stream on their platform just
because of what what is associated with
it yeah I think that's valid
um because yeah right now they just need
to clean up yeah they got to clean it up
yeah if they want like to be taken
seriously I think yeah because I think
right now of course they're making
headlines which is great they're making
headlines but and at the end of the day
it's like you need something sustainable
and the way I see what you know their
whatever their business model is
whatever their marketing is I don't know
if that's going to be something
sustained more in the long term uh
because at the end of the day you know
you look at YouTube and you look at us
who's been on the platform for a very
long time and even though the internet
is a very volatile place you want just a
little bit of adjustability there
wherever yeah
that was the that was the main reason
why I took a twitch deal was just to
have you know I I I was just pretty
straight up I was like I went up to
church I was like hey I would like a
deal uh for XXX reason and one of the
main one being is that I want to hire
more people I want to make more events
and to do that I need a a buffer a base
of money where I'd be like this is what
I can spend on on Twitch this year yeah
yeah
um and I'm totally fine with like losing
money on my twitch stuff because I
really believe in streaming and what I'm
doing right now and I'm very passionate
about it
um but also I'm not trying to go broke
so for me it was like I would like to
sign something even if it's maybe like I
know that maybe I can get more or maybe
I could negotiate elsewhere and yeah I
was like I just want to get moving with
this thing I really believe in what I'm
doing right now let's let's just do that
I think you're doing it the smart way
because you know I think a lot of you
know this is just speculation I don't
know what the the mentality of every
person who gets a 20 deal is going
through but like I think you know the
way you're doing it is smart because
it's like you're using that deal and the
money you're making from that deal to
basically be like hey twitch this is
what I can do you put me on right so
it's like that that you know hopefully
if twitch is a reasonable [__]
website uh they'll look at that and
being like oh okay well then he's making
great content for us you know because of
this deal so you're more likely I feel
to bring like if I was twitch I would
look at your stuff and be like oh okay
he's someone that we I'm happy to
re-sign yeah because they're making good
stuff whereas I think a lot of people
look at like these twitch deals and
these like contract deals for streaming
sites and being like Oh I mean they're
not really innovating they're kind of
doing the same [__] some of them just
get like even lazier because they're
complacent with the money that they've
already got right yeah yeah and so you
know I look at that and being like well
then what the [__] was the point of me
giving you all this money if you're not
gonna like do anything with it since
we're on social media websites Tick Tock
where do we rank that where do we rank
Tick Tock see Tick Tock is hard because
don't really trying to get his social
credit score
is hard I think because it's like I
think there's a lot of like awesome
stuff that's come out of Tick Tock but
there's also a lot of [__] that's come
out of tick tock it's like really kind
of sitting on both ends
yeah I I would say it's better than
twitch right now yeah I mean I I mean
it's like if twitch I don't already
compare them because they both do
different things yeah I mean that's an
experience yeah
I I I think uh it's just weird it's
short form content is kind of like it's
it's weird for me right just because not
not just because of the fact of short
form content but it's you know I've
already said that my life now in terms
of YouTube videos is run by an algorithm
and what it recommends to me but I at
least still
feel like I have a choice
I get presented with a page it's getting
into short form content is weird because
it feels like here is just a feed that
is being directly fed into your brain
and you will consume the content you
will consume whatever we present to you
yeah I like it it did something on
another platform it did at the time
which was just immediately play and show
you something yeah and not allow you to
stop yeah and then figure out not allow
you to choose yeah and figure out based
on that watch time and attention and all
that stuff like oh this is a smart
system of how because if someone's
looking at what short form content to
watch they're not going to pick anything
sometimes it takes longer to pick the
[__] thing than just watch something
yeah yeah it's a smart smart way about
it
um yeah not really a huge fan yeah I
mean it's okay do you think do you think
Tick Tock has uh completely changed a
whole generation of kids I feel like
with with Tick Tock and uh stop like you
know Tick Tock Instagram Snapchat as
well which is like
I don't even know Snapchat was still a
thing I've never felt more like a boomer
until someone talks about Snapchat and
how much [__] money Snapchat is
making I'm like holy [__] I am out of
touch right now you know I don't think
it's doing anything to our kids I think
it's the same it's probably what they
thought with us playing with like
[__] video games yes like yeah my
parents 100 felt the same thing
with Pokemon you don't have the
attention span to read a book yeah he's
in this weird Universe
the screen you know I feel like yeah he
can't watch anything unless Subway
Surfers playing at the same time what's
going on that's a little weird kids
these days I mean I've seen some potato
content where I'm like yeah I'm glad the
subway surfers
if it wasn't there I would skip that
[__] I mean it is certainly weird but I
think it's no different from what our
parents really felt with when we were
playing video games no of course yeah
when someone was on Tumblr probably
they're like oh my God
Tumblr yeah or before that newspapers
getting released yeah yeah like radio is
getting released I mean it's uh
I would like to get more into Tick Tock
but at the same time why not not get
more into Tick Tock but I would like to
be more aware about Tick Tock because
like obviously it's not I don't think
short form content is going to go
anywhere do I want short form content to
kind of take over no I'll I'll be honest
but I think it's kind of going to get to
the point where it is going to have a
much much bigger effect on just the kind
of media everyone consumes uh because I
remember when I started YouTube I'm
gonna go YouTube Boomer for a second
here
um I remember when I started YouTube uh
and YouTube was all about making videos
for desktops right when I started
YouTube in like 2007 there was like this
new feature that could tell you how many
people watched your YouTube video on
Mobile accounts and it was like two
percent yeah and I was like this is this
is such a non-factor why are we caring
about mobile watch time and now it's
just like the majority people majority
watch YouTube videos on a mobile device
and like I see the certain Trends where
as much as I complain about short form
content it is far too effective at
getting people's attention I I am like I
am one of I feel like I'm in the
minority where I have to like purposely
and consciously not watch too much short
form content because I can literally
feel my brain chemistry changing if I
watch it for more than 30 minutes I
reckon you know yeah yeah yeah it's it
yeah you you go into this trance and I'm
like this is too effective and just
because I'm aware of it don't feel like
how big and how widely spread Tick Tock
is right now I don't feel like people
would be would keep this in this in that
conscious mind to be like no I'm not
gonna watch this much you know it's uh
it's something that's going to continue
to be more and more of a big factor and
I think you know just for just to keep
up with the current times I should be
more aware of it yeah yeah
what do you think about Instagram
because you're you're the instagramer
here am I I mean you're the closest
thing to your Instagram here you're
using them I guess yeah Instagram for
detail for me easy a detail yeah I hate
it Instagram I think I think Instagram
is getting better in a lot of ways
because uh recently especially they've
really been putting effort into like
their reels which is essentially just
short form yeah yeah right and like that
has been like really blowing up I know
like I know Aki started to do like a
bunch of reels on Instagram and they've
done like stupidly well
um even better than our Tech talk so
it's like it is kind of fascinating how
that kind of content also is working
really well on Instagram and I feel like
at this point already like every single
social media like thing maybe like other
than Twitter is like really leaning
heavily into that like short form video
and like even you know dedicating spots
to their like UI to be like here's where
all the short form content is because
like on Instagram there's just like a
real section now that you can just go to
yeah and you can just infinitely scroll
short form videos and memes and stuff
like that on Instagram and like I'm now
when I'm looking for memes I go on
Instagram reels like it is the I think
it is the best place to find memes now
because it's like I used to you do that
on Twitter now Twitter has turned into a
[__] Cesspool of just like [__] I
don't want oh my God Twitter Twitter I
think now is Twitter's like an ET yeah
Twitter's like eat here yeah right like
for me now it used to be like sea tier B
tier because at least I I used to at
least have a poster too where I'd enjoy
going on Twitter
um but the more I the more Twitter has
gone into like Elon musk's Pockets the
more I'm like this is going lower and
lower into the tier list to the point
where I'm like maybe I should go on
Instagram I'm actually I'm actually
nowadays I found I'm using Instagram
more than Twitter yeah which is like
never happened in the the entire time
I've had both platforms like just
because again it's like you know I feel
Instagram is great because it's like you
know I like taking photos and I like you
know and I have a lot of photos of me
that you know Aki or whoever takes so
I'm just like I need a place to put them
up yeah and you know it's also just uh I
think a a nice I I feel like the
community on Instagram at least my
community is a lot more just chill on
Instagram like I can just I don't have
to add any like you know political or
anything like controversial to something
or can be misconstrued as that whereas
on Twitter I could say the most like
innocent [__] and people just
misconstrued in a completely different
way and you know that happens all the
time whereas on Instagram I feel it's a
lot more chill and again like the real
systems are really good uh you know like
looking through people's like stories
and stuff like that is like you can get
that done way faster on Instagram than
like going through each individual
person's like Twitter account to see
like what they're up to and stuff
because you know God knows you can't go
on YouTube uh you can't go on Twitter
anymore to be like I wonder what my
friends are up to because it never
[__] appears on your feed I think the
biggest thing I don't know if you've uh
I don't know if you guys have noted this
as well
um aside from the arguments which have
always been there on Twitter it there
seems to be I don't I don't know what to
call it but there seems to be a culture
on Twitter of like the slam dunk you
know
yeah just just I I guess racial culture
or something like that where ever it
just seems like everyone is looking for
that next stupid tweet to try the ratio
yeah I'm like it was funny when this was
first a thing but when I see this now
and on my feed there's some like ratio
attempts every like second or third
tweet literally every tweet I see you
open up the comments yeah and like I
guarantee within the first 10 replies
there will be someone trying to ratio
someone yeah and I'm just like what why
what are you trying to prove yeah what
are you trying to prove I'm like okay
the Fun's kind of worn off now this is
kind of getting tiring you know it's
it's kind of like oh it it kind of is
fatiguing in a way just to see this many
people trying to like slam dunk ratio
this stupid dumb person and I'm just
like Mitch you know maybe just let
stupid people be sometimes and I may
maybe just is it so wrong just maybe if
you stopped giving those stupid people
attention we would see less of it on
Twitter yeah yeah but the complete
office that is happening right now and
now it's just everything
sorry I saw the most cringe interaction
on Twitter whoa whoa go on
um
bro the amount of secondhand
embarrassment I got so like I don't know
if you saw this is this Mr Beast thing
it was with this guy oh he faked the
thumbnail no no no which one was let me
show you let me show you it okay this is
it's so bad oh my God the amount of
crunch so this dude tweet it you see
this one no actually just picked up this
beauty I don't don't I don't want to
show the Twitter account because I don't
want to give this guy any attention yeah
just put up this beat agreement but I
had an hour away from Greenville The
Hunt is on for Mr Beast so he he's got a
cardboard cut out and he's gonna take it
to Mr Beast right and Mr Bush replies
saying go away I don't want your stupid
cut out I'm tired of people harassing me
and then he goes the dude replies goes
yes sir I've never been more happy with
the rejection in my life oh my God and
then this dude like does like a video
later on on this Twitter being like
he goes like no see this is what I'm
talking about this is what my message
was about the whole time YouTube is a
platform keeps pushing us to be Cloud
Chasers oh my God I'm glad that I could
finally show that it had to stop I was
the one who finally you know got to to
show that it was time to change I can
see the YouTube title already with just
in in Brackets all caps social
experiment really like I'm like no
that's just coping bro I think you might
have deleted it because it was oh my God
this video of him
like like I will say just off that tweet
uh because you know this is definitely
not the first nor lost like you know uh
Jimmy dick writing tweet that I've seen
God the amount of Mr Beast dick riding
on Twitter holy [__] I'm like this dude
it is insane I know it is cool of course
he deleted it of course he deleted that
was that was Pete Quinn yeah he had a
video of him in his car with his friend
driving from like his Mr BEAST's Place
being like yeah
I just I'm just so happy that he said no
because you know this has gone too far
like YouTube as a platform keeps pushing
this and it's about time it stops and
I'm glad that I could finally be up and
I was just like what the [__] no no
this dude again please don't show any of
this this dude hit in his Twitter bar
being like let me teach you how to grow
your YouTube channel from one to one
million shots and it's just like bro
these absolute like like Barnacles of
human beings on the boat of YouTubers
just like absolutely desperate for
anything surprise he hasn't added into
his bio like officially rejected by Mr
Beast yeah I mean this is definitely
like my least favorite era of upcoming
YouTubers that are just absolutely like
Bottom Feeders to like they're like oh a
crumb of clout please no not the thing
that everyone is but like the people
that are like this yeah people that
behave like this yeah like absolutely
like just I mean instead of like
harassing people just for class they've
always been cloudy
that's that's one big Advantage I think
YouTube has over like a lot of other
platforms which I haven't really seen
anyone talk about which is YouTube just
has the advantage where you know we we
all we all we have there'll be cringe
young YouTubers but at the end of the
day there are actually role models on
YouTube they're they're actually people
that have matured up with the platform
just not out of like you know out of
necessity just out of just people
growing up yeah maybe people being on
the platform for a very very long time
and you know you look at you know
something like Tick Tock where there's
like the a [__] kid just committing
crimes in the UK or something like that
yeah like just just just like just like
the cloud chases let me just commit
crimes and film it and uh that's how I
gain attention and then it works and you
think about who all like who are like
the role models of tick tock you know
who is the one setting the presidents
and no one's really there right now just
because it's such a young kind of like
platform and even with twitch there is
just like only like a select few of
people that have been around that have
set a good example and are trying to set
a good example you know that's right
you're talking about you'll get that
you'll get that well you know like as
you were saying like I feel like you
know like I like to think the three of
us for example on YouTube have like done
a pretty good job of kind of maturing
with our audience and I guess with the
times not only because we're just
getting older in general we've been on
the platform for a while but just like
it's not even a necessity it's just like
like I never like stopped to think like
okay I've done YouTube for this long now
um I got I gotta be an adult I gotta
grow up I was like no I never had to
think about that because it's just like
now that I am older and I've been doing
it for so long like it's just like have
become a natural progression to be like
well my audience have stuck around is
older yeah my experiences have gotten
larger and me as a person has just
gotten older so here is naturally my
content now and people like be like he's
matured so much what an amazing lad it's
like no it's really it's really not that
like I feel I feel it's really hard to
do the opposite of that you know to be
like uh you know kind of have that like
uh I don't know what's the nice way to
put it but just like you know have have
a sense to be like okay you know now
that I am older and there are still
people watching me you know whether I
like it or not people are going to see
me as a role model and you know I feel
that because YouTube as a platform for
example has been around for so long that
now there are people who have you know
who are there from the beginning who are
now here where they are today who have
kind of understood that mentality
whereas Tick Tock for example is such a
younger demographic and hasn't been
around for as long especially as like a
place where role models are born that I
don't think there are a lot of people on
Tick Tock to just be like you know I've
been on Tick Tock now for six months uh
I need to start maturing I need I need
to be that role model no no one no one
has that mentality at the moment so like
maybe other people consciously think I I
they should become Role Models yeah
that's kind of a weird thing
people who are like I'm a role model
yeah I've I've never I've never tried or
even think I'm anything like that as
deep as I've gone is um I'm like at
which age is it no longer socially
acceptable to talk about anime titties
anymore that's that's basically how deep
I've gotten with it yeah exactly I'm
like when is this gonna be cringe uh
when am I when am I gonna stop doing
that and I haven't figured that out yet
I'm sure I figured that out a couple of
years slowly adapt with the time I mean
my's content has slowly changed over the
years it's less I mean there still is
it's like still like a lot of memes and
a lot of Comedy but there's a more
serious side to my content and I think
that just comes naturally with just
having less energy uh [__] you know
and again because you as a person has
matured as well right so I just feel
that's a natural progression for
anyone's content really you know like
you know like for like Conor my content
has been [__] way different compared
to like yeah 10 years ago yeah that's
not like a conscious Choice it's just
like yeah I just am not with this kind
of thing for me
I mean you didn't want to be the Black
Butler guy forever stupid Black Butler
and I was like I consciously want this
to change right but I was like I still
like creating stuff but just not this
stuff yeah yeah exactly um you know and
then uh I just kind of live stuff was
just really fun that wasn't conscious
though live was totally by accident yeah
but then I think there was a point where
I was like I would like to do this more
yeah and I'm kind of like consciously
doing it so I guess it's like a whole
it's experimenting a lot of happy
accidents and uh hopefully not wasting
time do you know do you know one social
media platform I've come back to being
finding confident and this is gonna
sound so fast if you say Facebook I'm
gonna kill you Facebook
okay okay hear me out hear me out okay
sometimes every once in a blue moon you
make a post on Facebook and it's just a
nice confident comforting thing knowing
that it's just your [__] family and
like your like the friends that you made
in high school that you don't know what
they've was what they've gotten up to in
[__] decades you go on Facebook every
now and again you see like what this
person oh this person got married oh
this person has kids now and it's just I
don't know that's it's like revisiting
your hometown after being away for like
years and that's just that's just like a
nice time I don't even remember
okay I have a I don't know if I've
struggled this before I've a bit of a
guilty pleasure on Facebook all right
um I basically went
in the area I grew up yeah unless you
just went around every local group on
Facebook like neighborhood watches and
joined them what
yeah because they post just the funniest
[__] yeah so you should generally you
should look it up the funny ones because
there's a bunch of like 56 year old
people yeah let me let me find one that
was they've sworn yesterday that made me
Cracker
uh wait how do you look at the name of
this group it's just like okay don't say
the name okay let me see it's just like
it's just like that's the town I grew up
in and I I joined this group and it's
just like oh my God they post is so
funny and like there's like like this
one like yeah
it's a
like they'll just post pictures right
like
does anyone recognize this person
they've been looking kind of shady yeah
it's just so funny because it's like
it's like Skyrim NPC Behavior yeah the
day that was like just funny van in the
neighborhood is anyone
it's funny because they they obviously
because like this is like their world
yeah
it's really fun just watching it and
seeing how like what kind of stuff that
they really care about right yeah it's
just kind of fun I don't know it feels
like participating in like people
watching yeah yeah it's great it's so
fun yeah I guess that's kind of what
you're into but yeah I don't I don't
like actively look but sometimes there's
some fun stuff I don't I don't actively
look at my Facebook but I don't know
it's gone from Facebook being cool to
Facebook being the the platform that
your mom uses yeah uh to Facebook being
cringe and now I'm just like compared to
compared to the [__] Tick Tock
Twitter
um like twitch all these other social
media platforms it's just nice to go on
a social media platform and feel like
you're just in your back in your small
town and it's just like a small
community that you are familiar with and
you know yeah um and I don't know
there's there's there's a chance there
and I every time I go on my Facebook I'm
like ah it's just nice to see what my
old mates what my old high school mates
are up to now you should join your local
news
you know what you know anyone who does
seem like something I'd enjoy all right
there's this post from Sue
whoever owns the dog that has barked
non-stop for an hour and a half at the
top of Village name please let your dog
in as it sounds in distress sounds like
a big dog and box three bucks at one
time other dogs are reacting to it so
the dog choir starts again yes I have a
dog but he doesn't bark constantly like
this and he would not be ignored like
this in the heat backlash expected but
whatever
expected 35 comments
why don't you go around and have a chat
with her she'll report it rather than
getting everyone involved it could be my
neighbor who has numerous dogs that bark
yep non-stop she doesn't care they're
all outside all day on the drive you
know what Sue is surely they're not in
the van and this heat it's just like
they're all heroes wear capes man it's
crazy the whole [__] Village comes
together to discuss a [__] dog
barking I love it it's so fun to watch
it's like the Town Hall in an RPG okay
actually no I I I I know I know why I
like Facebook because going on the going
on that platform seeing stuff like that
it actually feels like these
does anyone know that I'm missing
peacock is this is a picture of it
there's a [__] peacock why do they
have this in a small town
yeah it just cracks me up this [__] is
so wild it actually you you go on
Facebook you see these posts and it
actually feels like oh yeah these are
people yeah these are actually people
yeah these are people just dealing with
some like the most mundane [__] in their
lives and it's not like a million the
millionth Anime Avatar complaining about
some [__] thing in the latest Demon
Slayer episode I'm like oh these are
Facebook reminds me that there are
people who are behind all of these
accounts and there's there's a there's a
genuine I like that feeling I [__]
like that feeling you know what Facebook
you know what you're convincing me
you're convincing me to check out my
Facebook I don't know it makes me happy
knowing that like a lot of people just
have problems that are so minuscule that
is how they should spending I don't know
man like
watching I saw a peacock and uh just
stroll up in my neighborhood I thought
you know I was like what the [__] I just
love the idea of like there's a dog
barking I don't know where I'm just
gonna go and complain the Facebook group
yeah like to me that is like I don't
know why that's just so funny and I I
that's so cute yeah it's so wholesome
yeah but obviously to them it's very
serious issue yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think the reason I found out about it is
my brother I think he parked his car
somewhere one time and he was like I got
in trouble with the neighborhood watch
all the Karens were talking about me and
I was like what what the [__] I went on
this Facebook group and there was [__]
talking me I was like what the what the
[__] he's like who's this it's not
normally here it's like oh my God oh my
God yeah it's it's kind of like it's
kind of like The Slice of Life of uh
okay because okay there's like a
non-numberial yeah there's a thing right
there's a thing because a lot of people
today the to a lot of people these are
some of the biggest problems that they
end up dealing with and I remember like
there was okay this is this is like
dredging up a memory like a core memory
of like why one of one of the breaking
points I had when I decided to like
pursue YouTube as a career
um it was you know I was having this
meeting it was obviously in the BBC and
uh you know when you join a meeting and
not everyone's there right yeah so yeah
we had people from a lot of different
teams and we were waiting for someone to
join so you know you engage in small
talk and the moment I realized I was
going to leave was just uh I was trying
to engage in small talk with my like
some of my co-workers they are very very
different in age and one of them
mentioned that uh you know their bins
had been taken out like a day early and
then we got into this like five minute
conversation we we got into this five
minute conversation because yeah that's
oh no no that's when the recyclables get
taken off for me uh actually it's like
the uh actually it's um the Monday for
me is when the bins get taken out yeah
and and you know these are people you
know very very good at their job highly
respected
um you know respect to them uh they've
been there as a company for like [__]
years and I I just remember thinking
I just remember thinking I'm like this
is this is not the life for me yeah this
is this is not the life for me but I
want to be talking about [__] been
days yeah yeah but you know what like
there is there is a big there is a huge
difference between the problems that
they are dealing with and the problems
that you know as someone who's on the
permanently chronically online on the
internet uh just some of the stuff that
we that we have to deal with some
because every when you're chronically
online everything just seems to be a
problem well but again like I think
that's what's interesting right is that
the the it's all about perspective like
you know to us we'd hear this
conversation about oh [__] suit lost
her peacock
we'd just be like that's hilarious but
you know why is that a problem or you
know or the problem is so insignificant
but to them that's like actually eating
that's your peacock I mean yeah well you
know you know a dog barking too loud
right like but to them that's like
ruining their entire [__] week
whereas like the opposite can be
achieved of life so so what issues have
you had today it's like oh I go to I go
to bad I got a hate comment on my latest
video and it's not performing well and
they're like just get off the internet
yeah like Savannah's like why is that a
[__] issue I've had a dog barking for
the first three weeks that's the real
issue you know so it's interesting to
see that like kind of discrepancy and
it's like you know eventually I feel
like for people like us when we do you
know eventually like retire or you know
quit making content like I feel we're
gonna look back on like those problems
that we had on you know during our work
and being like that was cute now I have
to deal with this dog barking yeah I
mean to me the dog barking seems way
more of a real problem than some of the
[__] people can play on Twitter yeah
exactly exactly
um and you know that's I I I kind of
crave that actually like I think some of
the best NPC you said like you mentioned
NPC Behavior I think one of my favorite
uh NPC like Oblivion videos was just
like an old British woman complaining
about like construction workers way too
early yeah do you know this one
something about something about just
like they're on the roof working and
she's down there like you have to stop
yeah yeah but she's just like I've had
it with you and then she like blocks the
driveway yourself she does something she
takes her ladder and then everywhere and
then the construction workers are like
oh oh if you have a problem you can uh
bring it up with the owner the owner of
the house told us when to start
construction other than the there's this
like line that she says which is the
most Oblivion NPC line I've ever heard
in my life which is she pauses and she
goes right I'll talk to them then
then she walks off and talks to the
owner and I'm like oh so uh British
people and just Old Country towns they
are the real NPCs that's if you want the
true NPC I just see the hard like side
quests be gone after that line and then
walk off
yeah yeah there's people believing that
everyone is out to [__] them yeah ruin
their day I wonder how do you define NPC
Behavior like it's like because it
almost feels like otherworldly in a
sense of you're so disconnected from
reality that your behavior seems so
I think the one thing that really sets
off NPC behavior is like as you said
with that video they just say some
things right the perception of reality
yeah where it's like normal people don't
say this in this situation or like maybe
it's like too on the nose you know I I
would I would count NPC Behavior as you
look at a person and it almost feels
like they are scripted they are
programmed they're programmed they are
programmed into the [__] Matrix or
whatever you know
um but then that what makes NPCs feel
like NPCs is because they have just like
set dialogue that's very
rigid or yes I think it's that whole
idea of like you can't imagine what it's
like being them yeah you know or it's
like it's so detached from your
perception of life where it's just like
I cannot even start to imagine what this
person is thinking or why they would do
these certain things because it's just
like not real yeah we're getting really
yeah there's another one like a poached
man in the UK it's always the [__] UK
we just sound like NPC most people in
the UK argue over they're just the
[__] stupidest things you're really
getting there whereas in America are
they it'll it'll be a headline where
ends with someone getting shot yeah I
think I think it's just [__] filmed
and stupid fighting yeah I think it's
just because of the way British people
argue is so passive aggressive it just
feels like a scripted MP true true you
know it's confrontational but you don't
immediately see the consequences yeah
yeah exactly it's almost as if you know
like in game you know an NPC can't just
suddenly uh wouldn't just suddenly start
punching you or something yeah yeah you
you there are layers to it in terms of
you know choosing the right and wrong
dialogue options and that's what it
feels like talking to a British person
sometimes you know you choose the wrong
dialogue option they get a little bit
more passive aggressive a little bit
more Angry until finally it all kicks
off you know uh Peak NPC Behavior go to
It Go to
this podcast is brought to you by cash
app with tools for saving and spending
it's the best place for you to level up
your money and glow up your life Joey
you still owe
oh no when are you gonna pay that back
I'm so sorry if I I would have paid you
back sooner if only I had cash app
settle up all of those tabs all it takes
to pay someone is their phone number
email or hashtag you can even scan their
QR code straight from the app oh I'm
finally getting paid with cash IB you
can also keep track of your coin you'll
see your balance updated immediately so
you always know when a payment went
through safely and not only that you can
save on everyday spendings it's got
exclusive discounts with cash apps pay
and cash cards and you can Bank the way
you want a faster simpler way to bank
without so many fees you want to level
up in a video game right why not do that
with your life and your money so
download cash app today in the app store
or Google Play Store with the link in
the description down below with no
hidden fees and a free to order debit
card feels like a cheat code for your
finances making the cash out for the
sponsor of this episode back to the show
but hey one piece trailer looks yeah
while we're on something yeah while
we're on something topical as a
one-piece expert
well to be fair everything you probably
have
read right now is probably going to be
well not 100 yeah it's only going to go
off like I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so uh if you in case you missed it
uh Netflix right now is making a live
action one piece series it's coming out
the end of August
um and uh people are very divided about
it okay I wouldn't say people actually
divided I think there's a consensus yeah
the consensus is well I thought it was
gonna suck yeah uh it doesn't suck as
much as I thought it would I'm gonna say
something Brave okay all right I think
it's gonna be kind of sucky I think it's
gonna why is that right what there's
nothing
what is what is Brave
no the consensus is it looks decent but
I'm holding my breath yeah the consensus
was everyone thought it was going to
suck and then they're like oh maybe I'll
give this a chance yeah everyone was
expecting it to be like Dragon Ball
evolutions of that yeah right but so far
with this teaser trailer I personally am
like I have a I have positive skepticism
over where it's like I am almost looking
forward to this like I'm going to watch
it and if it ends up sucking it ends up
sucking whatever we can laugh about it
collectively afterwards but like I'm
kind of feeling after this trailer I am
my consensus on it is very similar to my
consensus after I first saw the Cowboy
Bebop trailer
which was it was an awesome trailer that
got me really excited about it and then
in the end it turned out to be not as
great as everyone was expecting it so I
feel that it might end up being that way
yeah because the thing about Cowboy
Bebop is that he had a [__] awesome
trailer the trailer actually like I
remember watching it and I was like this
is it this is this is going to be the
one that fixes everything that have cut
that has come before it it's like what
movie she chose involved they brought
back Yoko Kano like the stars had
aligned and then a giant Comet came and
destroyed all the stars yeah and I feel
like you can get a lot of the people who
are involved in the original
involved but it's still kind of tough to
translate it from animation to live
action and even with this one everyone
was like yeah man hood is involved and
it's a give it oh there's a manga artist
yeah sure it's his vision of the the
characters in the story about it's not a
filmmaker no he's not a he's not a TV
producer he you know it's it's it's a
lot harder to translate those skills and
I think people realize
um and a lot of the dialogue that might
work in anime and manga will seem
[__] goofy as [__] well that's why a
lot of live actions have just had this
reputation of being you know Paul's a
dog [__] because they think that there
is an exact correlation between how
anime characters talk and how real
actors talk which is unless your anime
series is super grounded in terms of
like dialogue like you know if we had
something like monster for example right
yeah or like you know 20th century boys
right or something which ended up being
a pretty decent live action only because
the dialogue is so grounded in reality
in the manga whereas one piece is like
the most Shonen you can get in terms of
like how characters act and how they
talk I really hope it's not like
some you know every [__] Marvel movie
Nash of quips and funny lines that
aren't funny I mean this is going to be
quick I just hope that it doesn't feel
like a cheap version of that because
even to me that the the quippy and
one-liners and Marvel feel like [__]
a lot of the one-liners in Cowboy Bebop
were like that as well which kind of
brought it down for a lot of people
where it's like live action Story the
live action yeah I I brought it down it
was already in the [__] yeah I mean
what was that one line is this black
male and what was it I think Jack goes
are you blackmailing me and the good the
woman goes well jet uh you are black and
you are male or something or something
like that which is like I would just
like
we're just like which out of context is
[__] hilarious which is like someone
really put this down on paper and
thought this is it like everyone yeah
it's like that's hilarious I'll put it
in it's like the most surface level [__]
yeah I mean I'm I'm interested I also
said as well I was thinking about it
when I was talking to some other people
I was like you know I think the first
Arc is the arc that'll probably be like
the easiest to film and then that's
because like one piece later on
Otis can't design just get [__] weird
yeah he's like how about I just make
somebody nine times the size of a human
and their body is just like literally
like a [__] uh what's the what's the
thing on Photoshop where you just make
someone like like deep fried or warped
yeah oh yeah like he just starts [__]
up with people's proportions and their
heads at 10 times the size it's like
this is gonna lead like ungodly amounts
of CGI yeah like and so now I'm like all
right this is the first Arc where you
can gauge if this is gonna do well I
mean it's just a crush
yeah even with like human characters
right or like characters that look at
him first woman who turns up and she's
like [__] massive and supposed to be
like super ugly and then she becomes
really attractive later on oh she starts
off and she looks like a brick [__]
of a woman yeah [__] are you gonna how
the hell is that gonna work well I mean
like even looking like looking like
doflamingo he's like a normal looking
dude visually but Oda was like What if I
made him 11 feet tall though yeah did
you have to do that like how do you make
Chopper not look like some kind of first
version of Sonic the Hedgehog well see
that's the thing like so interesting
yeah so when I when I made my video I
touched upon that being like I think it
was a good choice for them to cut it
right before where Chopper comes into
the story because I can not imagine this
like horrendous CGI Chopper just like
[__] running around with like all
these other people being like all right
you know what at least you were smart
enough to be like let's just stick to
like human characters first yeah and
then we can deal with the non-human
characters that come later on yeah well
even with like the human characters
there are there are some [__] weird
human characters and I think like even
just buggy the clown yeah uh which on
like the grand one-piece scale of things
is on like the less weirdest side of
things yeah but on like the normal anime
scale of things he's still [__] weird
when you think about like Mr Fantastic
right from Fantastic Four where he
stretches I was thinking I'm like yeah I
guess the suit does a lot of heavy
lifting with that because yeah you can
visualize the suit stretching and it
doesn't feel that weird when you see
Luffy's skin stretch like some kind of
budget Armstrong tour you're like it
just looks [__] weird yeah also I saw
like uh this interesting comment about
that which was like uh in that trailer
when his arm is stretching the scene is
quite dark which hides a lot of
blemishes in CGI so it was like I'm
already uh very skeptical on the CGI
purely I mean the [__] giant fish in
the trailer everyone liked the look at
that allowed just like this looks this
does look terrifying I'll give you that
but it's got it it's that uncanny kind
of like effect where it doesn't look
like a cartoon but it also doesn't look
like it should exist in reality it looks
like PS4 Graphics you know what I mean
where it's like it's realistic but not
realistic yeah I don't know if this is
me but like they just look like they
were like cosplaying like a DND thing a
lot of these to me I I know I know
that's such a nitpick but to me I'm like
man I don't know no no I I said exactly
the same thing
um they all look except for usop for
some reason
looks legit because he actually looks
and feels like a real person everyone
else looks like a cosplayer and I think
part of that reason is just because
whatever clothing you know they
obviously gave they were obviously very
um faithful to the original character
designs but I feel like that's a that's
that's actually an issue because the
clothes that that work can like anime
don't always translate well into like
live action and what what it what I got
from watching their kind of like
character designs is that their clothes
don't look like their clothes don't feel
worn you know yeah they all feel very
very clean and like okay let's let's
think about this a little bit deeper
right let's let's pretend that these are
real people for a second you know the
you have to wear these clothes every day
that would be like at least like a
little bit beaten up a little bit worn
maybe you'd learn how to like style it a
bit more but no these look like very
clean and pristine how they look in the
manga how they look in the anime they're
the cleanest Pirates
and I'm like this works for an anime and
a manga because okay they're wearing the
same clothes every day and it's like an
All-Star but as soon as you bring this
to reality this it's just the subtle
things yeah that give that that you
visually look and your brain just goes
something about the stands out you know
something yeah in the same vein though I
think
Netflix made a conscious choice to not
go full on with uh exactly replicating
certain character Styles and I think
that was a good thing like for example
like Sanji in this live action doesn't
have the curly eyebrow yeah doesn't have
the giant they're gonna give him a
lollipop though that's that's the big
thing yeah that's a cigarette then I'll
be like Mommy
but like I think like them not adding in
say like sanji's Curly eyebrow it stops
long nose I think was a good idea
because if they had added that in it
would have just looked incredibly tacky
yeah and it would have actually just
looked like cosplay yeah you know so you
know I think they made some conscious
choices to be like let's not include
this let's include this and I think in
general it looks a hell of a lot better
than a lot of other live action out
there and I think like especially with a
lot of like Japanese production live
action they try to be so faithful to how
the character looks that again you just
look at him being like that's not a
character that's a dude who just came
back from Comic Con like yeah you know
that's why right like for example like
the Fullmetal Alchemist live action was
so [__] because Ed just looked like a
cosplayer he didn't feel like I mean a
real person out of everyone on the straw
I had cream my least favorites I let's
say
potentially a bit take visually it's
probably Nami which if you think about
it should be like the easiest one out
right but like her hair was so bright
and it doesn't it just you know it kind
of just felt like it kind of just looked
like either she died that day or she put
on a wig like I said it just it's orange
isn't I like exactly an unnatural hair
color and isn't it in the real world
isn't that actress also naturally a
redhead
I think I saw pictures of that being
like why would they give her a wig when
she's just naturally a redhead yeah I
was just like okay that's a bit weird
yeah yeah I'm not sure myself but like
out of everyone she has the simplest
character design and I'm like you look
like a cosplay where you don't like Nami
as a character does not need to look
like a cosplayer at all it's so easy to
transfer her character over yeah I mean
that's just one shot you know well
that's that's all we were given well I'm
hoping I think I'm expecting it to be
bad and if it's good I'll be pleasantly
surprised yeah no I'm the same like I'm
definitely going to be watching it just
because I'm curious to see like if this
will be the one that I guess breaks the
streak uh so you know but um I'm not I'm
not expecting I'm not holding my breath
if I'm hoping for a direction I'm hoping
they go [__] it's it's hard to make
one piece work in live action but they
need to go like full Kung Fu Hustle the
original like Jim carries the mask to be
like okay this is Goofy but we're like
embracing the goofiness and uh we're
kind of like self-aware about it don't
try to like ground it too much
[__]
I won't be
there's just a scene where they just
look up and it's just like the Shadows
well you know I also saw as well being
like you know what guys we had the
bleach live action we're getting a
one-piece live action so now the big
three baby the last one Naruto live
action is just around the corner I'm
like if there's one show that is not
going to work in live action it's that
one I mean I I think what I think Naruto
would be easier to adapt than one piece
in my mind in my mind one piece is like
if they can do one piece they can do
anything right you know yeah it's I yeah
to me one there is nothing more
cartoonish than one yeah but you know
speaking of cartoons and animation on
topical uh we end up seeing the new
spite of us this weekend oh [__] I'm
actually seeing it tonight you're seeing
it tonight oh yeah okay yeah it was
incredible I think visually it was a
feast I think even like too good at
points really because like yeah because
I I was I'm watching it tonight so I was
like and it's been a while since I've
seen the first one and Aki's never seen
it so I was just like let me like
refresh myself before I watched the
second movie yeah goddamn that first
movie [__] amazing I always forget
how [__] amazing that show I think we
both said the first one we liked more
yes I think I like the first one more
just because the first one visually was
like it was incredible yeah
um and it kind of like showed me
something that I guess I'd never really
seen before like the best way I can
describe this is just like you know like
did you guys ever see the Matrix at all
yeah like when like when it came out
though you know when it was like three
was fresh yeah I was like five yeah
that's what I'm saying because like
three gone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
no what I was new and fresh
that's what I was trying to say you know
when the Matrix first came out it was
such like a visual Revolution it kind of
revolutionized visual effects Revolution
shut the [__] up Joey I swear to god
stop with your dad jokes for a second
Joey I'm trying to make a point here
nice one Joe thank you
but I like you know before the Matrix
came out no one had ever seen something
like the Matrix and you know bullet time
became a thing you know became the slow
motion effects whenever we see this
bullet time effect in kind of like
movies we'd be like ah it was like it's
the Matrix effect yeah it's the bullet
time effect that came from the Matrix
that's kind of how I felt watching the
first spider verse there was not there
had been that nothing
nothing had been released before that
had given me the visual sensation that's
the original Spider verse had given me
and it blew my [__] mind the point
where now I see like something like Puss
in Boots like two visually [__]
spectacular but I'm like well
spite of us did it first you know as far
as you know the story was so good this
story was really good but I'm like
visually I'm like I've seen this kind of
I've seen this kind of visual style
before and while I'm like ah they
obviously got they seem like they were
heavily influenced by what spider-verse
had laid out for them I'm not saying
it's just like oh spiderverse is better
than everything I'm just saying visually
it that that kind of laid the groundwork
yeah and spider verse 2 definitely took
things a step further it's it [__]
everything up it up everything to a
point where my brain did not have enough
time to process everything that was
happening
the way I described it was it's
literally like watching a movie with
Subway Surfers in the corner
there's like seven Subway Surfers
there's so much happenings Subway Surfer
the movie he's like almost almost went
to a detriment at times like I wish for
some scenes they would just let it
breathe yeah right but there's just too
many moments and like sometimes there'd
be a lot of text on screen and you can't
[__] read it yeah so [__] fast and
you're like yeah hold up pause hold on
and slow down was it good though like oh
yeah it was amazing but just it just I
think it would benefit a little bit from
slowing down right yeah at that point
there were points where there were so
many things going on I'm like my brain
needs to slow down to process everything
that is happening and then even even
when there are some more serious story
moments they're like okay let's just
change the color of the scene for every
single cut and I'm like yo can you slow
down for just a second so they did a
JoJo yeah yeah yeah yeah
there is no time to breathe in this
movie at all and you know it's it's a
good thing but when it's like you know
but I think my brain can process it in
the first film because it was like an
hour and a half or something this is two
hours and 20 minutes and it it puts it
puts its foot on the gas from like
minute five to minute uh to hour 200 uh
two hour two two hour twenty right you
know it never takes forth the gas and
I'm like holy [__] I I am I am exhausted
Jesus all right it is it is insane uh
yeah and I think like the story as well
is a little bit more like the first film
was a little bit more simple to follow
along with this one there's like oh
here's like 20 different characters and
20 different worlds doing 20 different
things and uh here's uh and then we're
gonna connect it all into one career and
storyline I'm like I've already like
that I really enjoyed that this is it's
just a lot it's it's a lot to keep the
only thing the only thing I know in this
second spider the first film is they do
they pay the homage to the 60 Spider-Man
memes quite a bit right
they they play they pay homage to a lot
of things I got a lot of different
spider verses and you can probably take
an entire [__] textbook and just just
to write about it basically but yeah
excited I'm excited to see it yeah I
think I think it's a film I definitely
need to see a second time just to fully
appreciate it yeah I I'm I I'm gonna
most certainly have to watch the next
one again before I watch the the one
after it at some point yeah oh yeah for
sure yeah it's it's a lot to process and
it's it makes me happy just to see you
know people that are passionate about
their work it's it's one of those films
where it's it's rare just to watch like
a piece of media and just to feel like
holy [__] the people really care they
they [__] cared oh yeah about making
the that's good they actually absolutely
yeah everyone did not have to go that
hard but they did anyway yeah and I like
I like normally my problem with
Spider-Man like as a character I I don't
actually find kind of boring but I like
I like miles a lot Spiderman I think
he's really fun no I agree I really like
what'd you find about what'd you find
boring about the Spider-Man character
well maybe this is because I watched the
Andrew Garfield ones last time
it's kind of like a
deaf actor is what I would kind of
describe him as he's kinda he's not the
most emotive right I guess it's kind of
like fun Nostalgia when I watched the
90s like 2000s yeah yeah for sure but
like I don't I I don't know well because
it's still I've never really found
Spider-Man as engaging as say Batman
both of them sounds so [__] dumb
thing about Spider-Man
my grandma and I always find way more
compelling as a character like edgy and
dark well I think it's because as well
like goat for actors the Tobey Maguire
films especially I feel maybe it's
because like it was still during that
era where like the Superman uh sorry not
Superman like superhero films were still
very much in like the cut and dry like
superhero styled like classic and
Spider-Man every other character is more
interesting than Spider-Man
I think in spite of us does a good
portrayal I just you know telling a
story of what Spider-Man is meant to be
uh like have you played the Spider-Man
Insomniac games at all no they're all
or well you you have one now yeah I'm
gonna [__] play Spider-Man yeah I I I
think I think the insomnia guy uh the
insomnia games does a very very good job
at portraying the kind of the kind of
character uh that Spider-Man's meant to
be uh because I think Toby Maguire I
agree I really do love the original
Spider-Man movies but to people guys
just a little bit flat to me
um like Spider-Man's always meant to
have meant to have had this kind of like
arrogance a little I like him though
it's like you know a little bit of
quirkiness to him and everything like
that which if it was Rob Pattinson
Spiderman well that's just yours
like my favorite Spider-Man was the
Spider-Man I grew up with which is like
the original 90s Spider-Man cartoon that
is that to me like the OG goaded
Spider-Man the big difference between
Spider-Man and Batman to me was I felt
like I could actually relate to
Spider-Man as a character or as Batman
was always just this super uber cool
thing that was more relatable to
Spider-Man uh all about Spider-Man feet
the fact that he delivers pizzas
more to a teenage superhero who's just
trying his best to live a double life
and just trying to get the [__] girl
that he likes or a [__] billionaire
playboy with dead parents I don't know
which one do I relate more to that's
just [__] no I actually studied
martial arts as well
with uh with what's his name
[Music]
what's the actor called who plays him
again the Irish guy taken which uh oh
Liam Neeson I was like which iteration
are we talking about
The Shadow Society
[Music]
the Spiderman's crushing it lately it's
good to see it's good yeah Tom Holland's
a good Spider-Man
um yeah yeah I mean like yeah Batman's
always been just like even as a kid I
was like this is a bit too edgy for me
it's no I loved Batman love Batman
the world of Gotham is the most
interesting out of all the I agree like
I think that Spider-Man is like New York
this Gotham's like it's Chicago mixed
with London mixed with New York it's
kind of like mixed with hell yeah it's
kind of this weird [__] up world
that's really cool and dark and grungy
yeah yeah I found it more interesting as
a concept but I mean that's just like
such a small nipple I've also just found
like the Batman films to just be more
interesting and well-made films compared
to the Spider-Man films just really
personally I mean they had the more in
my taste I feel I mean The Dark Knight
trilogy [__] okay the dog night
trilogy is I think the only one I'm
super like emotionally attached to I
like Batman Begins I mean that that was
good enough to like carry the whole
goddamn but I feel like I liked the Dark
Knight series just because it was like
it was a crime Thriller with people who
dressed up in a bat suit were you
telling me but also you don't like the
George Clooney Batman with Arnold
schwarzen the animated series was
insanely goated I watched it I it was so
[__] good that is good my camel's the
joker as well in that who is this is one
of the best performances in like
voiceover history it's so [__] good
it is I just I just never like I I never
liked it as a kid I don't know what why
didn't you if you like the Spider-Man
one you would have loved the Batman one
no because I did watch both I watched
both the Spider-Man animated series and
The Batman series
um I I think maybe that's why I didn't
like it was like really really grounded
and a bit too like Noir kind of like
feeling for me yeah I think I think I
just like I I think I first discovered
like the Batman uh cartoons and like you
know the early Batman films during a
time where I was just like oh I like
edgy stuffs whereas I looked at
Spider-Man I was like that's for
children
hello hello
mature 14 year old who uh likes dark
brooding things like Shadow the Hedge I
feel like you're like I'm no longer 12
now Mom put the Spider-Man costume 14.
it's Batman time and I never grew up my
favorites
I remember my favorite Spider-Man Arc
and This Is Me Maybe maybe this is this
shouldn't be a surprise to anyone any in
any way shape or form but my favorite
Spider-Man Arc from the original
animated series was
um The Arc where she he meets like the
Madame web or something like that and he
has to pick a bunch of superheroes to
transport to this other world to have
this [__] massive like war between
superheroes and super villains so I'm
like wait a minute this is uh I just
realized oh this is a [__] easy guy
that's why you love spiders
okay figured it out it wasn't all about
the attic groundbreaking animation or
anything maybe he just likes because
he's an Issa guy maybe I've maybe I've
never grown up maybe I've just liked the
same things I've liked as a kid all
along I also just realized like this far
into this discussion that this is
literally every discussion in every
comic book store across the world like
it's like what's better Spider-Man or
Batman
Okay hear me out that man into the
spider-verse uh yeah
yeah they go into other worlds it's cool
I like Crisis across infinite Earths
because it has like other so what you're
telling me is if they brought out a
Batman that's in Ithaca you would like
it
I mean there is that like I said I it's
it's the arc where um I think I think
it's cool yeah it does I think it's a
Justice League Arc it's like Crisis
across across infinite Earths I think
that I found I'm not uh I'm not a big
comic book person but there is my
favorite arcs were always the ones where
they cross over into like the other
worlds and the other Multiverse and the
Batmans meet the other Batmans and the
other Supermans meet the other Supermans
yeah that's that hey hey what can I say
it goes why is it always multiverses now
and I was like I don't [__] know
because they ran out of other [__] to
talk about I don't know I am sick and
tired of [__] multiverses do you know
do you know why they comic books or at
least not like not conference no no it's
not just that it's um they've just
reached the Dragon Ball problem where
you've you've taken on the biggest
threat of the world yeah and then you
take on the biggest threat of the Galaxy
which is [__] Thanos where'd you go
from what are you doing where do you go
after you save the entire universe what
about other universes I should follow
Jojo and then just likes JoJo you know
obviously had part three which is a
battle across the entire Earth and then
the next season they were like how about
we just have a little problem in this
little town and then it was actually
amazing so good because they sure he
just he was like [__] it no let's just
shrink this down let's make this all
contained in a single location and then
we can really experiment with that I
think I think that's what they need to
do is like what if we didn't do that and
then part eight is like let's just
[__] do LSD yeah right you know I
think we'll come out we'll have the LSD
Arc I'm sure but I think I think I would
appreciate if it was you know a bit more
ground which is why I like kind of like
uh so what you're Batman yeah Batman
Slice of Life the the Batman was kind of
like that is all containing Gotham yeah
one small kind of scale do you know do
you know what I realized recently when
when we're never going to get another
Thanos moment are we I was I was I was
really yeah I was re-watching uh like
Infinity war and like end game Clips
just
watching movie clips all the time
because I would like to relive some of
like the moments you know sometimes I'm
just can't be bothered to watch the
whole film you know you know with the
state of the MCU at the moment I'm like
that Wolverine you know that Wolverine
image like just like embracing the scene
from like end game to be like oh
remember the good old days because you
know I I you know obviously we did
realize how big it was back when it
first aired but I'm like man we really
did have we really did have our Luke I
am your father moment didn't we like
that that was you know I I still never
and you never [__] saw it because you
hate popular stuff no I hate Marvel
I respect that I wish I didn't try to
get sucked into this [__] pit that I
hate yeah I watch all of them and I hate
them all yeah exactly I just get angry
yeah I still watch them I don't know why
did you eat them before like end game I
started getting pretty tired of them
before it oh really I mean the last few
movies before endgame and infinity War
were kind of ass you gotta admit
they can't they they were they went and
came pretty cool we are like Thor three
which is like the best of the Thor
series
Ant-Man 2 which sucked we had uh Captain
Marvel which Captain Marvel sucks we got
a [__] black cat though my father was
good right never saw that that was quite
a while before though okay it was quite
a while before I think I remember
watching it was it was close yeah it was
like the I think it was like the year
before I definitely started feeling like
Marvel fatigue
right before but then end game was like
all right let's do it I'm [__] tired
about talking about end game we talked
about endgame so Marvel I hate Marvel so
much I'm done I'm done Spiderman
Spiderman it's the new cool thing now
Spider-Man in my head I kind of like it
was nice because I felt like the spider
verse was like oh my God it's out of
Marvel like it is Marvel property but
it's not in the [__] [__]
Universal everything has to be yeah and
just visually it's just a breath of
fresh air as well right you know you
know what I
um actually sad because I've I because
that's it
but you know you know what like are the
DC films actually underrated no actually
underrated already just released the
flash actually okay featuring a man
who's Crazy wait you're gonna have to
list it out for me because I've only
ever seen Batman which Batman
like
most of the Batman films I've seen have
you seen Batman vs Superman yeah I did
that [__] sucked okay name a good uh DC
film recently that isn't Batman Okay so
I no I when when when I talk about DC I
specifically am talking about the whole
the whatever the Schneider verse
I mean did you what did you watch the
slide I'm not watching the I'm not
watching a [__] who watches
hello me I watch the Schneider and
um probably the best version of the the
best movie in the Schneider verse so far
am I what other films are in the
Schneider verse
um
Superman what was the news what was the
Superman chords Man of Steel Man it was
Man of Steel and then Batman vs Superman
yeah and then it was Justice League
um okay but okay here's the thing here's
the thing I am sad that it got cut off
because I like the fact that I there
there are some absolutely Banger amazing
scenes in like okay they aren't good
films but they had some really
interesting ideas and yeah
um like one of my one of the I've seen
that sticks out to me I think I've
talked about this before was the
beginning of Batman versus Superman
where you see where you see Batman's
perspective the POV shot yeah the POV
shot of just Superman and yeah that was
pretty cool and like the other person uh
Zod just wrecking the city up and you
just realize holy [__] [__] me as a
human being I have absolutely zero power
and zero stake in whatever the [__] they
decide to fight over you see an apps you
see a city getting wrecked and you feel
so
um you see you feel so humbled right
because you feel like Batman is just
totally [__] powerless right and I
really like the con I really like that
idea the idea that they played around
that uh where you just see basically
Hume uh Superman being treated as a God
and then that's like a fake God because
if you think about it Superman kind of
is a God you know compare compared to
what's called like power yeah but how's
the ending how's the ending yeah the
ending sucked you know I know the first
five minutes of the Batman POV was the
only like good shot in the film yeah I
feel yeah the rest of it it just got
worse and worse yeah it it makes me sad
because I feel like some of these ideas
slowly coming into fruition in the
Schneider cuts of you know in in the
Justice League Shiner car where you you
kind of feel some of these ideas getting
to breathe a bit more and then obviously
it just got cut and uh we we have
something completely new now but it was
a breath of fresh air just to see a
totally serious take on superheroes that
didn't have equip every [__] five
minutes and just someone just seeing
someone try to just
portray a much darker side of
superheroes a much more serious side and
then he had the whole [__] Martha
thing and then everyone just checked out
and you're like okay whatever what else
is there in the DC side of things
because uh the only thing the only again
I'm not knowledgeable on DC [__] the
only thing I know is Batman there's
Wonder Woman which was a thing whereas
like who watched that which was uh I
mean first one was okay it was awful
yeah uh is Flash DC or is that yeah
flash is decent oh yes that's having a
great time yeah yeah I don't know I I
don't know why it's just when I watch a
d when I watch all of like squeaky's
chat existence when I watch the DC films
I'm like these are the most 5 out of 10
films with some 10 out of 10 ideas in
them that'd never get realized and it
makes me sad it makes me sad because
they have the potential to be reading I
think the best piece of superhero media
right now is just the boys yeah it's the
thing I enjoyed out of everything I've
watched in like the past since end game
that's by far the most thing I've
enjoyed Invincible as well
which is like it's not even any of these
guys and it's it's just a TV and it's
like this is great sure yeah it's not a
[__] stupid quip every two [__]
seconds making a joke it's like you know
it's it's diabolical in it she's [__]
yeah it's great I feel like they put
humor in organically and it's not like
quicker it's been uh 30 seconds we made
a funny one-liner guys we gotta write
something so
um
I feel like [__] off I'm not I'm not an
idiot like I don't need a [__] every
two seconds I feel like it works when
it's someone like [__] Iron Man with
Robert Downey Jr it would yeah that's
just his character yeah every character
needed to quit but even then after a
while it just got old or I'm just like
all right yeah we get they turned Thor
into like this very serious it used to
be a very serious character and I admit
he was too rigid but now they just
turned him into like just a budget like
Tony Stark impersonator one-line quick
thing it's just like this is boring yeah
and then and then you're like okay guys
but now we have Chris Pratt who does the
exact same [__] thing and then it's
like all right but then and then
everyone else Whiplash yeah it's just
like everyone it's like it's like a yeah
like you said it's like a [__] shitty
game of Jack box and Cards Against
Humanity everyone's gonna be the
funniest person in the room and it's
like not everyone needs to be can we
have a superhero movie where there's
just like zero one-liners no that would
be that would be kind of interesting to
see yeah if it holds up and it was like
even in Guardians of the Galaxy when I
watched that it was like yeah it was
like the only person who really
consistently landed them was like the uh
muscle big guy what's his name
Batista yeah he was his matched his
character all the time when Chris Pratt
did it I was like okay all right because
scratch just just be Chris Pratt stop
um you know so that was fun but
um yeah I I that's my opinions on yeah I
mean yeah yeah at the end of it I'm
excited to watch you'll like it yeah I'm
sure yeah tldr spite of us great
everyone everyone knows Twitter won't
shut the [__] up about it yeah like
impossible to avoid spoilers what it
taught me is that maybe we don't have
superhero fatigue maybe we just have mid
superhero movie fatigue yeah you know
yeah bold take
I think we have bad movies not only the
spices take some trash
um actually I I I've watched the um
Dungeons and dragon movie I don't say
this oh no that was actually really good
really yeah I don't know why it had to
be Dungeons and Dragons
it could have just been a fantasy film
well I think because they use a lot of
stuff that was in Dungeons and Dragons
in the like a lot of the creatures oh it
was good though yeah it's very fun
genuinely a pretty fun movie was it good
or was it just like acceptable no it was
fun it was good it was like actually
good okay
um it was very fun I had a great set
about it
uh dragons and dungeons like is it is it
done in though I know and I thought it
was going to be like a They're all
playing a game yeah
it's not like Never Ending Story
sometimes it's not like we have a
conversation every [__] you know yeah
I thought going into it it was going to
be people playing Dungeons and Dragons
and then it would be acting acting out
the scenes and it could be like well you
rolled a four oh I'll get critical hit
oh something like that you know I
thought it's gonna be like that and I
just didn't I I didn't want that yeah
and luckily wasn't that it was literally
just a fantasy thing okay that was just
used aspect of what I again I don't know
I don't play Dungeons and Dragons I
don't know which aspects were licensed
or not yeah I think spells Monsters
characters that were from Dungeons and
Dragons in the story right right but it
was like a uh kind of like a heist gone
wrong I don't remember what actually did
they ever introduced the dice roll
aspect no no no there's never a Dungeons
there's basically Dungeons and Dragons
characters
yeah it's basically just the a campaign
of Dungeons and Dragons kind of yeah
it's literally just imagine a campaign
but there was no there's no fourth wall
yeah because I thought for sure they
were going to do like what they did with
like Never Ending Story where it's like
there's a perspective of like them
playing there is a narrator
it's not from a person playing the
character it's from the character's
perspective narrates a little bit in the
start of your backstory but that's
during I mean it's all within the story
uh it's fun genuinely funny moments
um good honestly I I kind of hope it
does well because I'd love to see
another one I just want more fantasy I
want more fantasy well I I don't want
more superhero I want more fantasy I
know what you're gonna say let me tell
you an entire video
let me tell you an entire genre where
you can find them no no he wants good
fantasy I want good fantasy not big
tittied women who harems good I'll bring
me back Lord of the Rings give me elves
and and uh [__] dwarfs I just want to
get me with the boys going on a journey
I don't need MILF some [__] lollies
or anything like this [__] get the hell
out of here now give me Michelle too man
I I that's that's coming out next that's
next season I am very very excited
that's what I made Lord of the Rings the
goat it's just the boys on a journey
that's what made us so hard just the
[__] boys trying to get rid of the
the One Ring you know I mean you got the
Golem video game right
that's the representative nobody wanted
that I've heard so much about that but
like I don't know the details of it I
just heard that a lot of people are
hating on it yeah because it's literally
just it's more buggy than cyberpunk when
it came out and it wasn't even a good
game to begin with it's [__] the tell
the odd [__] you know how do you even
like so do you oh so you're gonna have
to explain this to me so do you play as
gold yeah yes
which is conceptually already the worst
[__] idea he's the least no one is
out of all the characters in Lord of the
Rings yeah there's a character that
nobody wanted to play as was [__]
Golem yeah give me a Legolas game yeah
you know what I mean come on something
you know anything
what I would love uh who lost who asked
for this no one asked yeah no one asked
give me like a heavy strategy game Lord
of the Rings where it's like Age of
Empires Lord of the Rings
come here give me a [__] movie that
is just in a similar inspired world
that's not [__] I don't know I'm
[__] done it's it's like doing a
Harry Potter video game be like uh what
I think people want to play as Dobby
actually I think that'll be really
interesting gameplay what's Dobby up to
like
exactly the same you know it's just like
who thought who thought playing as
Gollum would be a good [__] idea yeah
I know I just want more fantasy and less
I'm hoping it because you know we've had
a big option in fantasy hoping because
this movie kind of did I think it did
pretty well yeah I hope we get more
fantasy movies would love to see more
fantasy you mean kind of like the token
as kind of fantasy ah it doesn't have to
be that just kind of more set in like
kind of a medieval period or just kind
of an older period because you know Game
of Thrones popped off too as Dragon
popped off yeah dragons popped off it's
clearly him let's get more come on I do
not want more fantasy I don't want more
Lord of the Rings I want more sci-fi I
miss I agree sci-fi so [__] much okay
can we agree do you all agree as the
Council of [__] takes yeah less
superhero more sci-fi more more yeah
just less superheroes yeah actually
those those I've been preaching this for
years like please make it happen there's
there's I think a Sci-Fi series that I
have I'm very very excited about uh
and the reason was was because I was
like so staff for sci-fi that I was like
I'm gonna read books I'm I'm I'm
actually going to read well I mean
luckily we've had Dune which is yeah
okay okay
let me let me rephrase give me more
sci-fi that is not Star Wars I am the
same type of medieval give me more fancy
that is Lord of the Rings yeah yeah
um yeah
so me and the boys rocking up together
too bro we're like
[Applause]
I think is in production right now can
you confirm this Nabi is a series called
the three bodies problem or something
like that okay which was a Sci-Fi book
that I was very very interested in
Reading
um but it's about it's basically like I
think the premise of it which because I
I've already read the synopsis uh it's
basically
um there's something that proves that
all of like all of the scientific basis
and all like the mathematic basis which
we base all of our Sciences on is has
been proven like false so Einstein's
proof of theory is false and everything
like that and then you just see uh and
then scientists uh [__] and then you
just see the reaction of the world where
the F where everything that we believe
is false and wrong all of reality on
Twitter yeah like Twitter so basically
this is a movie where if what what would
happen to the world if someone L plus
ratio yeah yeah essentially essentially
it's like [__]
next year [__] yeah Netflix I I think
the this doesn't mean anything right now
but the show the show Runners for law of
four Game of Thrones is working on it so
that that can be a yes or a no okay okay
I mean I clearly though you're the one
thing you can't argue about the Game of
Thrones is and how's the dragon team is
that you know the writing staff were
[__] talented yeah when they were in
when they were crushing it in the older
Seasons yeah that was [__] like some
of the best dialogue we've had TV for
[__] decades
um I'm really glad really really really
really really happy that Dune did well
because like as a movie you're watching
it you're like this is like the complete
opposite of like a Marvel film where
it's like they are entrusting you so
much that you will get invested in this
world there's so I mean Dune is like the
first 30 minutes are pretty it's pretty
dialogue intense oh yeah and so the fact
that something like that can do well and
be successful in this climate of like
Cinema where it feels that like that
wasn't kind of welcome it's so good and
the fact that a part like it's a part
one and I was just I'm just so glad that
not to mention they they took away again
like as someone who's read the books
they took away so much info from the
books and yet it was still cohesive I
mean we've gushed about how gonna do
anything yeah I'm just glad I did well
and I really want more I'm I'm really
glad I did well as well and I I think
like you know my the latest example I
can think of is uh I'm gonna go on from
the tangent like Finland Saga season two
yeah where you know you look at Dune you
look at vinasaga season two where it's a
little bit slower than what you'd expect
audiences to gravitate towards but it's
a lot slower it's a lot more dialogue
more character driven but one thing
that's slowly been proven is that people
actually have patience if the first show
is good man if the show or story or
characters are good people will have the
patience to sit through that because
everyone thought that everyone was going
to drop villain Saga season two because
it was the Farmland Arc it was slower
and then what's happened uh it's kind of
popped off it's because it's given us
one of the best memes and one one of the
most widespread memes in recent memory
was like you have no enemies I'm like
how did the meme from Finland Saga
season two out of everything pop off of
tick pop off from Tick Tock man that's
like that's the biggest plot twist of uh
from season one
[Music]
give us more you don't you don't you
don't need like [__] Subway Surfer on
give us some good slow burners man yeah
that's what I want yeah give us some
good dramas
it's a tough sell but you know if if you
know shows like Steins Gate has proven
anything it's like you could be slow as
[__] but if you put if you stick it
through to the end then every everyone
can agree just how good it is you know
and I feel yeah we don't really get that
as much anymore because is it because of
people having shorter attention spans is
it because of the tick toe generation
hard to say but let's just blame
everything on Tick Tock I
that's just a byproduct of what's
happening but like you know it's it's
definitely just like I've seen a recent
Trend at least with like films where
it's just like we're not really getting
as many other slow burners or they're
not getting it I think I think it's
because the the landscape of like going
to the theater has changed drastically
yes absolutely so you know you you now
have to make your money on a movie in
the theater world before you know your
DVD sales and you could rely on those
kind of kind of supplement things yeah
yeah and I think now you when you when
it plays in theaters it has to sell so I
it made this kind of and streaming deals
didn't really make much as we learned
from the pandemic because you know even
like Warner Brothers that made um made a
bat not bad woman Catwoman what is it
what's it called uh they made a movie uh
a DC I think and it was completely done
but obviously I think there's a there's
a weird tax kind of thing where if you
scrap it you can save money and I
thought it was it was just wasn't even
worth releasing oh really save more
money from just scrapping
there's some kind of tax reason where if
they scrap it or don't release it they
can they can they can they get some kind
of thing on it and so I think we're at a
point where
movies have to perform at the theater
and so street is taking less risk which
meant more movies that you were easily
marketable and easy for people to
understand yeah
follow a formula less risk-taking and
then only sticking to kind of like very
well established directors as well so we
kind of you know it it I think the
reason it changes because of that not
because of uh not because of Subway
Surfers you know the pandemic also
[__] did a number on film and
theaters I I think I think it's it's too
easy to blame everything I was just like
I was just I know I know I know I'm just
saying just in case
you're gonna go off and be like shut up
we know we're not being serious don't
worry okay I don't know if this is going
to be a hot take or or not
I actually okay I want less things to
come out okay okay hear me out hear me
out okay I don't know because I'm am I
complaining about too much of like I
think no there is way more stuff coming
out that is true I mean there's like
five times the amount of TV series
coming out now yeah and it used to be
and and you know you you see this in
foot in the form of like every media not
just like TV series but like anime as
well I'm pretty sure like music and like
pretty much every form of like
entertainment and part of the big reason
for that is one the internet to the bar
of Entry to like make something is just
a lot lower nowadays
um but just means we get a lot of [__]
we get so much [__] to sieve through
it's pretty easy to shift through it do
you think so yeah it's gotten I think
it's gotten easier to sift through but
that doesn't really take away I guess
the stress of you know wanting to just
find something that is good and will
continue to be good right whereas like
you know back up when like those maybe
what like
15 20 anime made in a in an entire year
right like you know early 2000 [__] yeah
Boomers remember that how many new anime
released last season Joey
100. it's uh it is it was 55 I believe
yeah 55 shows yeah and two years ago it
was like 30. yeah like but like you know
you go back to like you know the early
to mid 2000s right when you know I
really started to kind of explore
everything like there was maybe only
like 30 shows to come out in an entire
year yeah so it was not only easier to
be able to look at everything and being
like all right what is it that I want to
watch what is it I don't want to watch
but now it's just like you have [__]
what 50 you said 55. you can't watch all
those videos
no no no no that's if you were to keep
up with everything that's watching two
uh two entire Seasons worth of anime
every week just to uh just to keep up
with everything coming up yeah yeah
that's too much and it's just like it's
there is what like you just don't have
the time to watch or play every video
game that comes out watch every movie
watch every TV series
um I kind of but like
it just seems like
sometimes
when you look at something like Netflix
and I feel like something like Netflix
is just pumping out just as much [__] as
they can they're just pumping out
they're pumping out stuff that I'm just
like this is this is like second monitor
[__] you know this is just [__] where
you I don't know what to watch because
there's so much so I'm just gonna put on
some background noise yeah so I'm just
gonna put on some crappy reality like
dating TV show and then you look at
something like HBO where I'm like wow
everything you put out is a [__]
Banger and I wish there were more
companies like HBO that just were like
so dedicated to instead of like pumping
out as much [__] as they could just like
curate the stuff that you have and just
make it as good as possible because I
feel like there's so much mediocrity now
everywhere everywhere there's so much
mediocrity now um instead of just
focusing on like good stuff that's yeah
that is gonna like stick with people you
know this is tough yeah how do you do
that in the age of streaming when anyone
you know you can just upload everything
uh yeah I mean there's not really a
downside to having more programming for
a lot of these websites or kind of TV
stations and I think a lot of people as
well will kind of take your point and
you know make the argument of like yeah
but you know you don't have to watch
everything like you you can make a you
can make a choice to like see a trailer
or something and be like ah no I don't
want to watch it or you know I'll
instead watch this but like I feel then
that kind of creates the problem of you
know ft like we've been talking about
this entire [__] episode of like yeah
there's too many [__] Marvel films
and now I'm fatigued over it even
earphones
fatigue yeah fatigue
um that sounds like that's like when you
play too much fatey
well I
like it so I'm I haven't watched most of
the Marvel films but I still have
fatigue over it because it's just like I
don't I want to stop [__] seeing it
even even just even just like seeing it
like just offhandedly like even a
trailer of people talking about it or
whatever I'm just like all right I get
it you know can we can we actually like
talk about something for some amount of
time before we just throw it away and
being like let's let's just new thing
now you know it's just like again like I
feel
it's just you know and Anime is the same
thing where it's like it's not so much I
don't want to see these shows it's just
that I just can't see these shows
because I now I'm confused I'm like all
right well [__] now before when there
was only maybe five shows I actually
wanted to watch now there's like 50
shows I want to watch but I can't
realistically watch all of them yeah I
feel like people would just move on so
quickly now yeah like once you've
finished one thing you're like marathon
in a day and you're like that was good
all right time for the next thing and
yeah and you're just like there's never
that that like if you missed the
conversation that happens the week after
season finale is you're just never gonna
talk to it talk about that thing I mean
you know recent animes is a great
example of that of being like you know
it's so incredibly hyped up while it's
airing and people will be like this is a
show that people are going to be talking
about for years to come yeah nine times
out of ten the moment the last episode
finishes everyone forgets about it yeah
yeah exactly right sometimes people are
like hyping up this new show it's not
just Anime but a week a week later the
new episode the new season starts and
everyone's like all right what's the new
shiny thing what's what's what's what's
uh what are we going to talk about today
exactly exactly I do miss the time
period where it did feel like everyone
had like a baseline of things that we
had all kind of like collectively
watched you know because I felt that way
not just with an anime but just like
just like with movies as well you know
if you find someone into movies you'd
have like you'd sort of had like a bass
line of just like classic movies that
everyone had seen yeah but now it just
seems like everyone has just random now
every every it's just [__] randomized
depending on what that person has been
recommended on Netflix or whatever and
like there isn't that same kind of sense
of community community like even with
just movie going watching where people
have like oh you've seen like the
classics right you've seen you've seen
these shows wait you haven't seen
[__] Terminator or Jurassic Park or
something like that you know what I mean
uh you know it would always start that
conversation but nowadays no one has
time to watch old movies yeah no someone
has time to watch the classics will go
back because there's just too much stuff
being made even though you should even
though Classics for a reason yeah yeah
yeah I I don't know I'm just I'm just a
boomer missing that oh man
missing your good old days exactly back
when everyone played you know every kind
of like back when everyone played the
same kind of thing back when everyone
was watching the same stuff playing the
same stuff listening to the same stuff
now it's just like it's harder to find
people to relate to because everyone is
because there's infinite possibilities
now of what anyone can watch and it's
like it's so hard now like especially if
you're not constantly watching all the
popular stuff you know that it's it's
very difficult to be like oh did you
watch that one show that I really
enjoyed and they'll be like never heard
of it yeah exactly
well I think you definitely have heard
of is the trash taste podcast you're
listening to it right now yes yes
that's right you're listening to it I
don't know why you'd be 150 something
episodes
but uh hey look at these patrons though
they've definitely heard of the show
yeah and they love it so much that
they're supporting us directly so that
we can make great content for you guys
and if you would like to support us
directly as well then head on over to
patreon.com trash taste links in the
description also follow us on Twitter
send us your memes on the song Reddit
follow us on Twitter send us a memes on
the subreddit and if you had our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
sorry for all the the Boomer talk today
goodbye I'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]
thank you